[Music]
never in the history of competitive
Starcraft has there been a rivalry
nearly as important and influential as
flash there's even a strong case to be
made that it's the greatest rivalry in
the history of competitive gaming before
the days of world's Ti and the overwatch
League there was south korean starcraft
brood war and at a time when fans were
worried about brood war declining flash
and Jay Tom's legendary bouts helped the
game from fading into obscurity
the ushered in a new golden age for
StarCraft but more importantly paved the
way for the birth of eSports as we know
it the thing that continues to make
flash and j dongs rivalry so special is
that it came at a time when nobody was
expecting it by 2007 South Korea's
Starcraft obsessed netizens had been
devouring brood war since its launch in
1998 and the game hadn't sinned a patch
since 2001 people were starting to fear
that the game had been figured out that
there was nothing left a theory craft
that the game's glory days were coming
to an end in the years before flash and
Jaedong Starcraft competitive circuit
had been dominated by four players who
can't be known as the bones whopper
originally Bonzo was a Buddhist term a
self elevating first-person pronoun kind
of like calling yourself master in
StarCraft however it became a historical
term used to describe those who were
agreed upon to be the true masters of
the game
boxer nada I love you and Savior and the
first player to push
warpath Savior was Ebisu an up-and-comer
who managed to sweep in and one of the
most revolutionary series of all time
[Applause]
bisous overthrew the king of starcraft
but to everyone's surprise he didn't
become the next bones why enter jaedong
whose astronomical rise near the end of
2007 turned him into a legend still
considered the greatest suruc player of
all time jaden quickly became renowned
for his sheer unadulterated aggression
epitomized by the e hun timing maneuver
with which he humbled storm
this new era of broodwar was
characterized by a never-before-seen of
volatility no longer was there one a
recurring champion instead there were
several contenders fighting for the
throne the age of the bones WA had come
to an end and the age of tech bonaly
sang a term combining the names and
nicknames of B sue stork Jaedong and
soon enough a rookie named flash had
begun Flash's entrance onto the scene
was quiet his first claim to fame was an
ingenious cheese he used to knock Ebisu
out of the round of 8 and OSL
Wow
the Terran rookie remained relatively
unexceptional until he managed to secure
draws against Jaedong at both MSL and
OSL starcraft most prestigious
tournaments the community began to
suspect that flash may be j dongs
kryptonite flash went on to confront
Jaedong in a series of tense
history-making face-off that ushered in
the most cutthroat era starcraft has
ever seen the first was a best-of-five
series at 2008 gaume TV msl season 4
flash only managed to win one game but
it was enough to prove that he was ready
to go toe-to-toe with the best player in
the world
the second was a best-of-three face-off
in the quarterfinals of OSL where
against every odd flash toppled a
heavily favored Jaedong two-to-one
the 15-year old flash went on to win the
event becoming the youngest champion in
Starling history but his victory over
gay DOM is what sent shockwaves through
the community he had proven that the
tyrant j dongs newly acquired nickname
could fall it would be nearly two years
before flash and Jaedong would meet in a
major league Grand Finals
2010's Nate MSM but Game three of that
final Sauer the experience not because
it was uneventful but because they
didn't actually finish it to shut down
the thick that the garbage mashers on
the detention level because they were
squeezing into tighter and tighter
situations and yeah the video that we're
watching is just gone blank so what the
heck is going on something crazy is
going on it looks like a Kaspar referee
has come out finally gonna do something
useful apart from just standing by the
players and making sure on YouTube busy
put an annotation I report the results
of Game three involved it's all oh crap
I missed it we in the consideration of
the resource situation is and expansions
therefore we decided and found in favor
under summary trial of KeSPA Starcraft
Code section 13 that Jaedong appeared to
be in the lead
what oh my god oh oh my god oh my god if
this wasn't old if this wasn't crazy
enough so there are they it's a mind
reading you're right mulch up there
giving the game TJ Dante someone's game
crashed I think or something like that
happened and the game was lost and
they've reviewed the situation and
decided that Jaden was in the lead and
awarded him the
game flash went on to lose game four and
ultimately the tournament the match
everyone had been waiting for was ruined
and it was all because of a space heater
and some faulty wiring
if these players never faced off again
in another major final the fans would
have felt cheated but they did face off
and the best was yet to come
in 2010 flash and Jaedong made history
by meeting in the finals of three
consecutive msl's nate hana day two and
big file and the years last OSL aside
from nate flash won them all flash went
on to not only solidify himself as the
winner of his rivalry with Jaedong but
the fifth final and greatest bourgeois
of all time he boasted a 70% win rate in
every matchup and the longest time spent
as the number one player on caspere's
ranking flash has earned several
nicknames over the years little monster
the living weapon some Jaedong in
particular even referred to him as God
he's an opponent that I I respect the
most these are flashes of God is
touching the respect is for you the
thing is it's likely that flash wouldn't
have become the game's indisputable best
unless Jae dong pushed him to get there
likewise Jae dong would have been the
indisputable best player if flash hadn't
shown up and taken his crown at the end
of the KeSPA era when all was said and
done their final map score was 25 to 24
in Flash's favor both flash and Jae dong
went on to play Starcraft 2 but never
really saw the success they had in brood
war flash stayed on with kt rolster
becoming something of a father figure to
the south korean starcraft scene and the
country's most revered competitor jay
tom joined Evil Geniuses in 2012 and was
quickly welcomed into the West as one of
eSports greatest living legends to this
day it's difficult to overstate the
adoration but fans around the world have
for Jae dong and his anime s plight
against flash they retired in 2015 and
sixteen respectively but with the
release of StarCraft remastered their
rivalry has been reignited still they'll
always be remembered for the days they
spent as legends in a late Arab reward
in collages case for being a god and in
j dongs case for being the only man who
could make that God a bully for bringing
Starcraft to a truly international
audience I love America and for laying
the groundwork for an entirely new
generation of competitive gaming this
was like the prehistory of eSports is
Starcraft one like that era team houses
for these guys yes like all of that all
the efforts I believe our players ever
all down to a pyramid and at the top are
flash and Jada for turning themselves
and each other into eSports first Titans
warring gods whose epic exploits will be
forever inscribed in the annals of
history thanks for watching if you want
more great content just like this be
sure to hit the subscribe button